Joe really stepped in it so this is this
is probably the worst moment he had a
couple sort of somewhat befuddled
moments but overall you know they had
his face freshly botoxed and his hair
plugs were good and the makeup was right
and his eyeball didn't explode overall
it was pretty decent the packaging of
the whole thing but he did have one
major major Gaff when asked about China
and Taiwan but would U.S forces defend
the island yes if in fact there was an
unprecedented attack after our interview
a White House official told us U.S
policy has not changed officially the
U.S will not say whether American forces
would defend Taiwan but the
commander-in-chief had a view of his own
so unlike Ukraine to be clear sir U.S
forces U.S men and women would defend
Taiwan in the event of a Chinese
Invasion yeah there was something kind
of funny there if you're just like an
Insider TV person how quickly the edit
there from Biden basically saying yeah
troops to oh but the White House is
saying no way
so this is just him saying something
either without knowing what he's saying
or what our policy is or anything else
it's also a crazy thing to say that if
China was to invade Taiwan which I would
not be for and let me be 100 clear I
believe that Taiwan is a independent
nation every independent nation has a
right to Define its borders and defend
its borders as it sees fit and we should
be allies with Taiwan and all of those
things
um he's saying we're going to send
troops I mean troops those are soldiers
those are human lives of Americans to
fight what does he mean to fight on the
ground in Taiwan against China halfway
across the world it's just a crazy
proposition now you could say uh if
China invaded Taiwan or tried to Annex
Taiwan or whatever it is that we would
maybe sanction them putting aside the
validity of sanctions or anything else
we could sanction them we could try to
do do something in the U.N we could
maybe arm the Taiwanese what we're going
to send troops there it's just a it's
just an insane thing it's also an
interesting thing because in light of
what's going on with Ukraine where we're
in a war but we're not in a war we're
funding the war we're you know giving
endless dollars for the war we're giving
weapons but we haven't declared war
there's no debate about war it's just
like more nonsense so immediately
obviously the administration had to walk
that one back